some companies are testing a four-day
workweek to see if it makes employees
more productive a New Zealand estate
planning company had more than 240
workers try four-day work week third a
four-day sorry 32 hour work week in less
than two months the employees maintain
job performance levels but reported
having less stress and a 24% improvement
in their work-life balance
several large companies in the u.s. such
as Deloitte KPMG and Ryan already offer
four-day work weeks Derek Thompson is a
senior editor writes about workplace
issues for the Atlantic magazine welcome
in good morning good morning so is this
a niche thing or can this really be
something that companies across the
board could try I think when you look at
this or any other work entrepreneurial
policy it's important remember what work
is and work as three things work as
money its product and its meaning and
when you're put when you're implementing
a policy like this it's important to be
serious about what are you trying to
optimize you're trying to make more
money or you're trying to make work more
meaningful for your employees I think
what you see with these experiments is
not that a four-day workweek necessarily
makes workers more productive overall
but rather than an it improves job
satisfaction it improves meaning for
these workers because they can spend
more time with their businesses don't
make money they cease to exist
absolutely I'm not saying it makes them
less productive I'm saying they see
there's no sort of I mean it's always
happen in this academic sort of sense
like wouldn't it be better if but how
does it affect the bottom line yeah I
think what you saw here is that it
didn't affect the bottom line and
there's a New Zealand company it didn't
affect the bottom line for Deloitte KPMG
it doesn't seem to affect their bottom
line either but not every company is a
consulting company or an audit company
it's easier for these sort of companies
to implement a four-day workweek
precisely because a lot of the work that
you see here is a desk job right you
might call you might figure out what
exactly what you need to do and then you
do the work at the desk job
not every work is like that and so you
can't have a four-day workweek for every
single job that exists I grew up in San
Antonio Texas and the largest and one of
the largest employers there is USAA the
banking institution but they decided
long ago was that four days would be
good and then do 10 11 hours a day and
that that way people would spend less
time commuting back and forth and for
banking some people were
work Monday through Thursday some people
would work Tuesday through Saturday and
then it makes it a job that everybody
wants right yeah this is our retail
works right you have retailers who work
retail workers work four day weeks that
doesn't mean that Uniqlo is only opened
four days that week it means that they
stagger their work have you found
anything about the way in which people
change their attitudes though if I know
I'm working four days a week then I am a
little bit more productive because I
want to get it done I think it's
absolutely possible you know work
productivity is a little bit like REM in
sleeping you don't your head doesn't hit
the pillow and boom you're in REM it
takes time you sort of your thoughts
start to meander and then finally you
enter REM it's the same with work you
can't sit down at the desk and
immediately enter deep work productivity
right now if they don't do it so a
downside yes there's a downside if there
are people who are already overworked
for those five days and you say we'll
take that five-day productivity and just
sort of make you do it in four days
that's gonna be even more stressful and
then there's a lot of companies that
just can't do this if you were an
executive recruiting company for example
and you constantly have to take meetings
with outside people and suddenly you say
oh I don't take meetings on Mondays I
don't take meetings on Fridays well
that's really frustrating to the very
people you're trying to recruit so it's
not as though every single company is
equally receptive to this idea but
rather that I think these sort of
entrepreneurial policies to improve job
satisfaction and productivity are
exactly the sort of thing that we should
be doing to work like that if you're
receptive and your company's not Thank
You Derek thank you